Martin haider's seminal essay the
question concerning technology is an
important one not only for consideration
of exactly what it's title talks about
the the notion of
Technology what technology is the
effects that it has on us how it
interfaces with the human being but it's
also helpful I think for understanding
haider's attitudes toward
not only modernity but also towards
metaphysics and towards being more
generally but it really is an essay that
is is focused critically on our current
modern condition whether we understand
that as the modernity of haider's own
time the the middle of the the last
century or if we understand it in terms
of what people call late modernity or
postmodernity late capitalism uh there's
a lot of of different names for it the
the current condition that we're in
where these these questions and these
issues that haiger has his finger on are
becoming even more pressing they're sort
of raised to a higher power so this is a
very important essay fortunately it's
fairly short it's not as dense as all of
haider's works it it ends up making
reference to quite a lot of other themes
like truth or AA as revealing or
unconcealed uh he talks about
Aristotle's four causes in a very
interesting way uh he's focused on the
question of essence that we'll get get
to in just a few
moments but before we do that I wanted
to sort of give you a a general
thumbnail sketch of of where he's going
with all of
this heiger thinks that our conventional
sort of kneejerk
immediate conceptions about technology
are well in a certain sense correct
they're also in a certain sense off
based they conceal more than they reveal
to us they don't actually show us what
technology really is and what technology
really does and how the human being as
such dine is intimately connected with
it it tends to take a kind of
external view on it that doesn't
necessarily leave the human being out
but even doesn't fully understand how
human beings interface with technology
and what he's going to do is lead us
away from that sort of perspective very
early on uh what he calls the
instrumental and anthropological
perspective on
technology he's going to bring us into
traditional metaphysics not in in in
order to endorse it
wholesale but in order to say that
Aristotle was right about certain things
but also didn't
adequately think through or
conceptualize or carry out his work as a
phenomenologist to the degree that he
ought to have then heiger is going to go
on from there to to draw a lot of
conclusions having to do with this
notion of of Truth and revealing and
what tech or the word we get technology
from consists in how it's tied in with
epistem science disciplinary
knowledge then he's going to bring us to
a sort of a a Crux where he says is
modern
technology is the technology of the
mechanized Industrial Age is it
something radically different from
previous technology because remember
human beings who had technology from the
beginning of History hisory actually
prehistory you know if you think about
Flint wrapping and uh skinning animals
and producing pelts that's early
technology that's doing something with
the natural environment making
tools uh very early on we figured out
how to make tools to make other tools
Aristotle by by his own time so we're
talking about um 23 24 centuries ago
already is talking about the hand as the
tool of tool tools and talking about
slaves as and sold tools and speculating
by the way Arles when who gave us the
word technology
techn um speculating about the
possibility of these kind of fairy tale
things like like looms that would weave
themselves and how that would transform
Society so the notion of technology has
been with us for a long time is it
radically different in the Modern Age
whether we're talking talking about the
early modern age when natural science is
becoming uh really physics and and and
then chemistry and later on biology are
becoming the basis for a lot of thinking
and working things
out uh whether we're talking about the
Industrial Age where now we have tools
being used to create tools being used to
create tools and and so on and so forth
or whether we're talking about what they
nowadays call po Industrial societ
heiger is
asking does all of that change the game
is there a radical shift and his answer
is yes and no he's going to bring in
this conception of what he calls
standing
reserve and in German bishan and this is
going to be something that
is you could say essential although
that's perhaps not not exactly the right
word for it it is the central feature in
the mod modern attitude towards
technology so that's where we're going
you notice I've put a few things up here
as starting
points he's questioning about the
essence of
technology early on he says
um we'll be questioning concerning
technology questioning builds away so
he's not concerned with simply asking a
question and then like a catechist
looking for answers right away
questioning itself is a mode of thinking
and it's not something that you want to
hasten it's not something that you want
to try to you know place within
categories from the beginning you want
true questioning means being attentive
to what it is that you're asking
questions about if you're questioning a
person you actually want to pay
attention to them you don't want to
pigeon hole them immediately and not
allow them to express what it is that
they have to express if you're
questioning concerning a text you
actually want to read the the text let
the text work on you if you're
questioning this is kind of a trivial
instance questioning concerning coffee
you know what kind of coffee is this
where did it come from what does it
taste like what does the taste reveal to
me you have to be patient in order to
question
adequately questioning is part of
haider's
phenomenological or metaphysical
method so he says we want to question
concerning technology and in so doing we
would like to prepare a free
relationship to it so that's going to be
a key concern running through this
entire thing a free relationship and
I've put this in quotes because that's
the term that he uses what is a free
relationship he tells us uh and this is
an early sort of sketch of it the
relationship will be free if it opens
our human existence to the essence of
technology so already here we're looking
at a connection between existence and
Essence we're trying to see how they
fuse together how does my existance as a
human
being how does that find itself revealed
in finding out what the essence not the
instances not just the examples not just
how it affects me but the essence of
Technology human beings by by the way
for haiger are by their very nature
questioning beings that is part of what
makes us the kind of being that we are
the very special kind of being that he
calls dozen so where he's going to go
from this is thinking about technology
as a
means as a human activity and he's going
to say this is actually quite correct
and then what he's going to do is say it
is
correct but
superficial when we're engaged in
philosophy if we're doing the kind of
philosophy that heiger is we may
acknowledge the correctness of the
correct we may acknowledge its
usefulness for
communication we don't have to throw it
away we don't have to reject it as some
sort of neolites with respect to
technology but what we have to recognize
is that everything that's genuinely
important when we go to its roots to its
foundation to its
Essence this is not going to help
us as a matter of
fact this can stand in the way this ends
up distracting us providing us a screen
a concealment to use heiger terms from
carrying
out a genuinely metaphysical inquiry and
by metaphysical he means revealing to us
gradually stage by
stage aided by the way by the insights
of previous metaphysicians like Plato or
Aristotle or all the way to n showing to
us what the Essences of the things
are that's a activity that takes quite a
bit of work so let's get ourselves up to
that point he starts out by saying
technology is not equivalent to the
essence of Technology what does he mean
by that that little phrase technology in
the sense of what we're used to
encountering you know and and Technology
can be as crude as writing on a
chalkboard or diagramming things on a
chalkboard or the Press which took the
the chalk and pressed it into this form
and then put it into boxes which then
were sold sold which then made their way
to me and I uh believe I probably took
this out of a classroom came in my
pocket cuz I have a tendency to shove a
chalk in my pocket as I lecture and you
know if you think about it there's
technology involved in all sorts of
steps there those all there's all sorts
of examples or instances of technology
these glasses are technology they allow
me to be able to see we're using
technology right now to record
this none of those are the essence of
Technology so what does he mean by
Essence he says when we're seeking the
essence of tree for example we have to
become aware of what pervades every tree
as tree and that it's not itself a tree
that can be encountered among the other
trees the essence of Technology will not
be a piece of technology it will not be
one single pattern or mode of Technology
very often we go astray when we're
trying to think of the Essences of
things by identifying them with one
particular particular example or one
paradigmatic example and saying that
that one can then substitute for
everything that's not really the case
not at least when we're doing
metaphysics we want to know for all the
things that we call
technology what is it that they have in
common what runs through all of them and
unites them we're not just looking for
some sort of notional characteristic
some quality that we can say they all
have in common what we're really looking
for haiger is going to steer us
towards here's giving away some of the
the answer is in large part the human
comportment and the human making meaning
out of
technology so let's see where he goes he
says we will never experience our
relationship to the essence of
technology so long as we merely
represent and pursue the
technological so long as we remain
within a certain attitude toward te
technology where we're comparing pieces
of Technology against each other where
we're playing with it where we're using
it where we're becoming more and more
obsessed with it where we read reports
about it where we troubleshoot it we're
not actually engaging with the essence
of Technology likewise he
says if we only put up with it or evade
it so it's not just overly positive
attitudes toward te technology that keep
people from being able to experience the
essence of it and thereby have this free
relationship of their existence towards
technology it's also
the viewing it as something that just
has to be endured that has to be put put
up with that one has to come to terms
with or the rejection of it the saying
technology it's all bad we need to get
back to the Garden or pick whatever you
know hippie Trope that you
like um or ran Trooper emersonian troop
or you know has been around for for
quite a while this
sentiment none of those really allow us
access to the essence of Technology none
of those
help us understand what technology in
itself is so he says everywhere we
remain free and chain to technology
whether we passionately affirm or deny
it but we're delivered to over to it in
the worst possible way when we regard it
as something
neutral there is this common notion that
to understand technology we should be
value free and merely understand
technology as something that can be used
for good or bad or efficiency or
non-efficiency that it carries no values
with it it doesn't steer us towards
anything it's a pure means to be used by
human beings however they
like that's not true every time that we
introduce technology we change our
trajectory to a certain
extent so he says um
according to ancient Doctrine if we want
to talk about
metaphysics the essence of a thing is
considered to be what the thing is we
ask the question concerning technology
when we ask what it is so that seems
pretty straightforward doesn't it one
says technology is a means to an
end other says technology is a human
activity and haiger says do we have to
choose between these no they're both
right technology is in fact a means to
an end I write on the chalkboard in
order to
convey Words which are supposed to
convey thoughts to you and I use another
piece of technology this camera in order
to do that and then I'll be uploading it
on my computer I'm gesturing over there
because that's where it happens to be
right now and while I'm doing that I'll
be sitting in my office chair which has
been adjusted to the the proper fit for
my body and the place will be
illuminated by electric lights
um my computer will be charging while I
while I do that I'll be plugging this
this flip cam into it all these things
are means to certain ends and they're
also human activities they are the
product of human enginuity of innovation
of making things out of other
things so he says these two come
together why well
because positing means for ends is the
distinctively human
activity that's part of what we are we
are beings that actually say I want to
do this how do I make that happen what
things do I need to do along the
way these go together so technology
becomes what haiger calls an
instrumentum an instrument a tool an
aid and he
says who would ever deny that this is
correct it is an obvious Conformity with
what we're envisaging when we talk about
technology this is where a lot of
conversations about technology actually
begin says the instrumental definition
of technology is indeed so uncannily
correct that it even holds for modern
technology not only holds for ancient
technology like say a mortar and pestle
it holds for as modern technology as the
iPhone or the computer network or the
banking system so he says
um even the power plant with its
turbines and generators is a man-made
means to an end established by man even
the jet aircraft and highfrequency
apparatus are means to ends a radar
station is of course less simple than a
Weather
Vein
but this much remains correct modern
technology 2 is a means to an end that
is why the instrumental conception of
Technology conditions this is an
important thing it says conditions every
attempt to try to understand technology
when we begin our discussions of
Technology this is the def facto or
default position that people begin with
in
mind and is it is it correct yes it is
it is correct is it adequate it's not
adequate it doesn't give us what we need
doesn't tell tell us the the essence he
says everything depends on our
manipulating technology and the proper
maners and means we will as we say get
technology intelligently in hand we will
Master it and the will to Mastery says
becomes all the more urgent the more
technology threatens to slip from Human
control so you know think now for an
just a contemporary example that haiger
didn't have access to think about all
these people on their phones spending
all this time
and the technology that can be used
which actually you can upload as an app
on your phone to tell you hey knock off
playing around on your phone you spent x
amount of hours on it so far you need to
actually do some real life you know
putting it quotes because working on
your phone is real life too it's just a
smaller part of the real life you need
to get back to all these other
things we use technology to try to
control technology which has gotten out
out of hand and all of that is
reflective of what haiger calls a will
to
Mastery now here is where we're going to
start making our transition he
says suppose now that technology were no
no mere
means that this is actually
incorrect how would it stand with the
will to master
it and he says wait didn't didn't we
just say that this this notion of it as
a means was correct and he says yeah it
it's correct
however in order to be correct this
fixing by no means needs to uncover the
thing in question in its Essence only at
the point where such an uncovering
happens does the true come out haiger
says we're only really fully aware of
what's going on with our
technology when we can get away from
this
correct but inadequate
conception and what is going to be our
access point for that is going to be
getting away from Mere practice or you
might say a physics of the apparent to
metaphysics thinking about what really
is going on
here so he
says only at the point where such an
uncovering happens do we find the true
for that reason the merely correct is
not the true there's a different
between the true and the
correct accordingly the correct
instrumental definition of Technology
still does not show us Technology's
Essence in order that we may arrive at
this we must seek the True by the way of
the correct we must ask what is the
instrumental we have to make that into a
question
what is the
instrumental we ask that we place
ourself on the road to actually
understand what is technology within
what does such mean such things as means
and end
belong so he says wherever whatever has
an effect as its consequence is called a
cause uh a means is that whereby
something is affected and thus attained
so we're moving from just means and ends
to talk talk
about causality cause and
effect something
deeper so he says the end that
determines a can means to be used may
also be considered a cause Aristotle
talked about this Plato actually hinted
at this they call this a final cause
says wherever means and ends are are
employed wherever instrumentality Reigns
there Reigns
causality this is where he's going to
move now to talk about the four causes
so we want to pause for a moment and
just think about where we've come so far
we've gotten away from being enraptured
or being en soral or being bewildered by
thinking that this is an adequate
understanding of Technology we've
realized that if we want to genuinely
pose the question of what is technology
what how how does it really work how
does it really interact with human
beings not just essentially but
existentially we have to move now to the
realm of
metaphysics wherever instrumentality
Reigns there is causality that's one of
the things that heiger has said so far
what does that mean so he's going to now
explore this in terms of what may be
familiar to to many of you as the four
Clauses that we get from Aristotle and
these are sort of Scholastic ways of
talking about them that haiger uses in
this he uses the example of a silver
chalice which we'll come to momentarily
and he says that
um for centuries philosophy has taught
there are four causes
the cause of materialis the material the
matter out of which a silver chalice is
made the ca formala the form the shape
into which the material enters the the
shape the structure of it the CAA
finalis the the uh reason the end for
example the sacrificial right in
relation to which the required chalice
is determined as to its form and matter
so notice that already caus ofenis is
binding these together it's not just a
matter of form being imposed on matter
the reason the end is is important and
then he says the
caen which brings about the effect that
is the finished actual chalice in this
case the silver smith so we have the
traditional you know conception Silver
Chalice shape sacrificial right silver
smith we can do this with many other
things Baker uh flower water
yeast loaf I suppose you could say that
that the baking it is is also a way of
introducing form to it and perhaps the
the reason is to make money perhaps the
reason is to gratify the the pallet and
the belly at the same time perhaps the
reason is to make uh bread for the king
who knows there could be a lot of
different reasons here the point is we
have for a long time looked at
causality in this way so heiger then
says um what technology is when
represented as a means discloses itself
when we Trace instrumentality back to
this four-fold quality well
why well when it when it comes to
technology we can ask what is it made of
think of a pliers for example very
simple technology what is it made of
steel what is the form the shape of the
pliers you know and if you were to
adequately describe that you would have
to talk about you know the gripping
surface and how many teeth there are and
the the little nut that you have to hold
them together um probably you'd talk
about the the
um covering or the the rough surface on
on the handle so you could use it what
is the final cause of it so that you can
grip things even better notice that uh
it's a piece of technology that allows
you to do things with with technology
and then what's the cause of fans the
the efficient cause the producing cause
the factory that produced the pliers
perhaps Uh Sears Craftsman you know
company um the individual person who
operated the DI press and then you know
the one who assembled the things all
these can be understood in that way and
the process by which all these causes
are integrated with each other is a more
complex one but this allows us a schema
by which we can make sense of it so
heiger
says
suppose that causality for its part is
veiled in darkness with respect to what
it
is let's say things are not as simple as
this and I don't mean that we can
complicate the picture more that's not
what haiger means either what he's
talking about when he's saying perhaps
it's not so simple as this is that
perhaps these things are not what we
took them to
be he says we've acted as if the
doctrine of four causes had fallen from
Heaven as is a truth as clear as
daylight but might it be that the time
has come to ask why are there only four
causes it's a good question why four in
relation to the afor mentioned four what
does cause really mean what is the
essence of
cause that connects all of these
together and notice what he's going to
say next and I'm not going to read it
directly I'm going to just sort of
summarize it for
you not only in
modernity but it's more pronounced in
modernity but even in ancient times
there was a tendency to make this
one into the cause of causes the
Paradigm for for causes if you look at
modern philosophy you will see this at
least certain modern philosophy like
Dart for
example you will see this becoming very
very starkly clear and in some of cart
successors like liet liet is trying to
bring back final causes into this schema
because the carians had tried to reduce
everything basically to efficient
causes causing things to take on a
certain form or
shape and what they were made
of so he says the caus ofans sets a
standard for all
causality this goes so far we no longer
even count this last one pelic finality
as
causality and heer wants to get at
something different which is actually
going to make this one more important he
says what what what does cause really
mean he
says if we're if we're looking at uh in
certain Latin
terms Kaa kasus belongs to the verb
kadre to fall and it has to do with why
things turn out in a certain way so he
says the doctrine of the four causes
goes back to Aristotle but everything
that later ages seek and Greek thought
under the
conception has nothing to do at all with
bringing about an affecting what we call
cause in
germana and the Romans call Kaa is
called
ion by the
Greeks what does that actually mean that
to which something is
indebted the four causes he says are
always all belonging at once to each
other of being responsible to something
else so these are
interconnected with each other and
they're all ways
of being
responsible that may strike you as a
rather anthropomorphic way of talking
about things if you think about the
Silver
Chalice the metal the silver itself is
responsible for the being of the Chalice
for it being the kind of thing that it
is being made of silver having the
characteristics that it does because of
that material he says it is
co-responsible for the Chalice The
Chalice is indebted to that is owes
thanks to the silver for that of which
it
consists but the sacrifice sacrificial
vessel is indebted not only to the
silver as a chalice that which is
indebted to the silver appears in the
aspect of a chalice in its form in its
structure in its shape in its in
Greek why is it a chalice and NTI says a
brooch or a
ring why an iPhone and not just a whole
bunch of parts all through thrown
together because it has a
structure why a
cup and not a cylinder that has a hole
at the
bottom wouldn't be much of a cup if it
if it had that would it so he says both
of these are responsible for it then he
says there remains yet a third something
that is above all responsible for that
sacrificial vessel it is that which in
advance confines the chice within the
realm of Consecration and bestowal
through this the Chalice is
circumscribed as sacrificial vessel
circumscribing gives bounds to the thing
so not only do we have form being
imposed on matter why is form imposed on
matter because the final
cause which really isn't a final cause
in the sense of temporality it predes
the whole working the whole
manufacturing process the final cause
the reason for the Chalice being made
out of silver and made as a
chalice is the rituals that it's going
to be used for the meaning that it
possesses for human
beings so this is in a certain sense
more important more causal you might say
so he says um
finally there's a fourth participant in
the responsibility for the finished
sacrificial sacrificial vessels lying
before us ready to use the silver
smith what is the silver smith the
silver smith is a worker who for the
reasons over here imparts the form to
the material and thereby produces a
chalice so he says um the silver smith
but not at all because he in working
brings about the finished sacrificial
chales if it were the effect of a making
the silver smith is actually not a causa
aians why it says the Aristo tilian
Doctrine neither knows the cause that is
named by this term nor uses a Greek word
that would correspond to it so haiger is
introducing something new
here let's put to silver
smith silver smith is a
maker and he's not the same thing as the
ca of
fans why
not because it's not so simple or or so
reducible or so direct as that he's
involved in something he says the the
silver smith considers carefully and
gathers together the three
aforementioned ways of being responsible
and indebted so the silver smith is
gathering in all of this the form the
the matter the final
end to consider carefully is in Greek
lean from which we get logos we actually
the opposite too lean is rooted in appus
Thy appus Thy is a word that means to
bring forth to
show to in some ways set before the Gaze
before the visibility of of others to
bring into existence
to bring into
being the silver smith is co-responsible
as that from which the sacred vessels
being brought forth in subsistence take
and retain their first departure he says
so what's going on here heiger is
revealed to us by questioning by
carrying on this process of
metaphysical examination of what's
actually going on using an example of a
silver smith a worker a shaper of an
object that is a form of
Technology he has shown us that things
are not as simple with the causality
schema as we we thought they were the
four
causes actually are not all on the same
level and the silver smith himself
doesn't fit adequately into this schema
of the four
causes so he
says
um for ways of owing hold Sway in the
sacrificial vessel that lies before us
they differ from each other yet they
belong together what unites them from
the beginning now we're going to a
deeper question in what does this
playing in unison of the four ways of
being responsible play what is the
source of the unity of the four causes
where after all does the owing and being
responsible mean thought as the Greeks
thought
it he says today we're we're too
inclined when we hear the word
responsibility or being responsible to
think about it in ways that are going to
lead us astray so he talks about as
owing like having done something wrong
having um let somebody
down uh as a lapse or we construe them
in terms of of affecting and he says in
either case we Bor from ourselves the
way to the Primal meaning of the word
the the metaphysics of it here now
haiger is going to make a very important
move which connects this discussion of
the four
causes and of technology and of
producing with some of his other Notions
that he has elaborated in other works
such as being in time but also what is
metaphysics the nature of
Truth um all sorts of well also the the
uh discussions of the the work of art
what's going going on here is haiger is
now going to
illuminate what happens when we make
something so he says that uh we can
understand these four causes now in
terms of four ways of being
responsible and this is the language
that he uses he talks about
occasioning and he says that we have to
be very careful not to get misled by
other uses of this term occasioning he
means something very broad something
metaphysical something that has to do
with the nature of being and activity
itself so he says these four ways what
they do is they bring something into
appearance what does he mean by
appearance there just The Superficial
outside of the thing no he means that
they allow things to actually appear as
things for things that perceive them as
things that is
now that I've probably confused you a
little bit with all this thing
language when something comes into
appearance it shows four human subjects
four human beings which are able to see
those things as objects which are able
to imbue them with meaning to allow
meaning to acre to them to make sense of
them to make use of them to talk about
them
that's something that's that's involved
in this bringing into appearance so when
the silver smith makes the
Chalice he doesn't merely take matter
which then he stamps a form onto and
says there you go put it in the package
and get the hell out of
here he is bringing something into
being he is making something that human
beings can then look at and say aha
that's a chalice or they can say aha I
don't know what the hell that is what is
it and they can they can be provoked to
question about it they can mistake it
even the possibility of being able to
mistake it relies on it being brought
into appearance heiger also says that
this this work of occasioning these
these causes they let the thing come
forth into presence he uses language
here which is not so much the language
of agency like you know pushing pushing
pushing but rather cajoling saying come
on come on come on with me you want to
to be you want to exist now here's your
chance heiger is saying this about the
silver he's saying this about the form
he's saying this about the purpose the
final end and he's saying this about the
maker or shaper or techn
noo so what else does he say he uses
this language beautiful language of
actually setting the thing free starting
it down on its way I'm going to read you
the passage because it's so so
wonderful the four ways of being
responsible set it free to that place
and so start it on its way namely into
its complete
arrival think about that for a
moment and think about the the artistic
the creative the even work ad
manufacturing process as allowing
something to be what it's going to be as
allowing it to assume the shape and the
purpose that lies latent dormant within
it as
potentiality beautiful thought there so
heiger then says the principal
characteristic of being responsible is
this starting something on its way into
arrival on the basis of a look at what
the Greeks experienced in being
responsible we now give this verb to
occasion a more inclusive meaning so
that's what causality is doing that's
what
instrumentality and causality are
involving according to heiger so he
says in what then does the playing in
unison of the four ways of occasioning
play these let that these let what is
not yet presence arrive into Pres
presing what is not yet present what is
not yet in
being
visible tangible can now come out the
silver can assume the shape of a chalice
which then can be used for this within
the context of this
ritual and the person making it already
has all of these things in mind if they
really know what they're doing so he
says accordingly they're unified Le
governed by a bringing that brings what
presen is into appearance and he he
makes this reference to Plato's
Symposium at this point um every
occasion for whatever passes beyond the
non-present and goes forward into
presencing is pois bringing forth that's
haider's gloss on this passage things
are coming from non-being or
non-presence into presence and he says
that we're not only talking here about
handicraft manufacturer not only
artistic and poetic bringing into
appearance and concrete imagery so we're
not just talking about the Weaver the
Shoemaker the poet the politician who
brings order into things we're also
talking about the realm of what the
Greeks called fusus which is often
translated as nature and Haider whenever
he brings up the word fusus he almost
always picks up on the notion of
upspringing um things in nature swell up
they come out of their their
potentiality into existence think about
a seed blossoming is this a beautiful
thing to watch think about a a um a
plant seed whether it's a monocot or or
diecut uh it's it's always a beautiful
thing to see the the the rupture of the
seed husk the new plant coming forth and
seeking out
sustenance maybe it'll die maybe it
won't maybe it'll root itself and and
grow grow and become something but
that's the realm of fusus and this takes
place within fusus as well um so he says
now what is brought forth by The Artisan
or the artist has the eruption belonging
to Bringing
forth but not in itself the way that
that nature
does but in another who's the
other the other is the silver smith the
Craftsman or the
artist so heiger says the modes of
occasioning the four causes are at play
Then within bringing forth through
bringing forth the growing things of
nature as well as whatever is completed
through the craft and the Arts come at
any given time to their appearance so
what we have here is a metaphysics in
which that which was not comes to be and
doesn't come to be just immediately but
often times in steps in stages in
processes sometimes it comes to be by
its own intern process of development
sometimes it comes to be by something
taking it and saying I'm going to do
something better with you I'm going to
make you do something I'm going to take
this Flint here
which theoretically could turn itself
into an arrowe head but probably isn't
going to and I'm going to wrap it until
it becomes an arrowhead I don't know if
this is the right technique for for
doing that I'm just sort of making that
up imaginatively but you get the point
so he says um
how does this bringing forth happen
whether it's in nature or handycraft and
art occasioning has to do with the
presencing bringing into presence of
that which at any time comes to
appearance in the bringing forth
bringing forth brings out of here we
have some other important hiigaran terms
bringing forth means going from
concealment to
unconcealed The Chalice is in a certain
respect there in the
silver but it takes the The Chalice
maker the silver smith to to make that
be the
case now the Greek word for
this is
ala
that's also the word for
truth so heiger is playing off of this
this is very typical heider and saying
the truth of the thing is its
unconcealment it's coming to being out
of
literally non-being other being nothing
whatever you want to say so he
says this coming rests and moves freely
within what we call revealing the Greek
have this word ala for revealing the
Romans translate this with Veritas we
say truth and usually understand it as
correctness of
representation so he's going to ask now
where have we strayed to how did we end
up here from
technology and he's going to take stock
for a moment and then he's going to move
further into this question of
Technology taking truth and
unconcealment as our leading
clue heiger has led us at this point in
the essay to this what we might call
equation unconcealment is ala or what
the Greeks call Ala which is also what
they call truth and that corresponds to
haider's notion of Truth as
unconcealment or as revealing and and
unconcealment is not something merely
visual or
conceptual
it means to actually bring into being to
allow to be present to be actual to be
active to be engaging for us to be
meaningful so the truth of something is
in a certain respect it's very being
being on the scene for us humans now and
heiger is going to say that this notion
of bringing forth of bringing into to
appearance gathers and rules the four
modes of occasioning that he's talked
about before what he has transformed the
four causes the four traditional
Aristotelian causes into uh remember
that the maker he says doesn't really
fit the the efficient cause quite as
well as we'd like it to be all these
four causes all these four modes of
occasioning are ways in which something
is responsible for the being or the
being that or the being there of what is
the Silver Chalice
exists not only because form was
impressed on matter but because of the
larger encompassing final cause the the
reason the good the end for which it
exists the project that it is a part of
and it also exists because some being
some being that is able to set itself PR
projects a doine in
haider's technical sense of the term a
human being who is an artisan actually
devoted thought and craft and attention
and time and effort and said I'm going
to bring all these together now even
more encompassing of them is this action
of bringing forth it gathers and rules
these four modes of occasioning he
says going even further than that it
also encompasses the relationship of
ends and means in determining what ends
we ought to pursue and what means are
are the best means for occasioning those
ends it also includes instrumentality
itself so remember we've been asking
about instrumentality why we've been tra
you know traping through causality
because we're interested in technology
so what is technology then here's where
we're coming once again to another
Crescendo in in one of the early
movements in this piece what is
technology technology is a mode of
revealing of bringing into
being of introducing meaning where there
was just incoit perhaps chaotic or not
even fully
perceived things it's not to say that it
manufactures radically new being where
there was nothing existing before but it
organizes it structures it
gives life sense reality to
things so he says technology is
therefore no mere means technology is a
way of
revealing if we give heed to this then
another whole realm for the essence of
Technology will open itself up for us
the realm of revealing that is truth and
he says I know this sounds rather
strange this is going to be a little bit
mindblowing but go along with me on this
and see where we're going to go with
this so how is technology revealing and
he
says well let's think about the word
Tech itself what is techic so the Greeks
use this term let me put this on the
board um the s use this word
Tech to talk about a kind of ability a
kind of capacity that human beings had a
Potter making his his uh wears at The
Potter's Wheel possesses a technic he
knows just how fast to move the wheel he
knows where to place his hands he knows
what sort of clay demands what sort of
shape what can be done with it he
discovers new things but on the basis of
of the tech that he already
possesses he can push the tech further
along with this it goes another term
that the Greeks often
used epistemy from which we get
epistemology the study of
knowledge epist was Tech was was tended
to be used for things like um political
science
generalship although in certain respects
those might have been better understood
as Technic
Aristotle used the word tech for
rhetoric the you know art of rhetoric is
the tech rhetoric
case um very often they use these terms
in a kind of kind of loose sense as as
as equivalent for each other uh
Aristotle tried to distinguish fairly
rigidly between Tech and epistem but
they're both ways of bringing truth to
things they both have their their own
truth Tech has truth in
production so he says Tech is a mode of
Alan that's the verb for ala to to bring
into truth it reveals whatever does not
bring itself forth and does not yet hear
lie before us whatever can look and turn
out now one way and now another what
does he mean by
that well you know if you again if we
use the pottery example you know any pot
that you're working on could shift
break you can make the same clay into
many different
implements you don't have to glaze it
the way that you do but once you've
actually created a product it has a
certain determinacy to it it has been
brought into being somebody can look at
it say I like that pot or that's an ugly
pot or this is good for my coffee or
this will not look good for my coffee in
the morning because it's it's too rough
for my my mouth all these sort of
determinate relations can arise once it
has come into
being so Tech reveals things to us he
says whoever builds a house or a ship or
forges a sacrificial chalice reveals
what is to be brought forth according to
the terms of the four modes of
occasioning all of these go with each
other it's not like first at the
beginning there's the worker and then
the worker imposes the form onto the
matter and then only afterwards they
figure out what the hell to do with this
stuff no that what to do with it the
purpose that mode of occasioning is
already there from the beginning and a
good worker one who has Tech is thinking
how can I actually make these things
come together how can I take my activity
the efficient cause how can I take this
matter how can I take this notion this
form that I've got and how can I make
this reveal
itself where it wasn't before so now
here's a chall D now here's a house now
here's a a map for a city now here's
persuasion if we want to use Aristotle's
art of rhetoric or rather the means of
persuasion so he says this revealing
gathers together in advance the aspect
in matter of ship or house with a view
to the finished thing envisioned as
completed that's something worth
thinking about lingering over the person
who has Tech is not just sort of
puttering around
and seeing what
happens they have an an idea in mind to
begin
with and that idea is not merely the
the form of it it's already the
purpose of it and it already includes
their activity of working and it may it
may modify itself and take on greater
determinacy over time it may actually
change it may steer them off in
different
directions but he says it's envisioned
as completed and from this Gathering
it's determines the matter of its
construction so what's decisive in
techne is not in the making and
manipulating nor in the using of means
but rather in the
revealing that's what's decisive in Tech
that it reveals that it brings forth
that it produces something where there
wasn't something
before so he says technology is a mode
of revealing technology comes to
presence in the realm where revealing
and unconcealment take place where ala
or truth
happens now haiger is going to to bring
up a a worry that we might have once
again can this actually apply to modern
technology is modern
technology which seems to be much more
convoluted seems to be a somewhat
different process seems to have attained
a degree of complexity and penetration
not only of the human being but of our
entire
environment that previous technology did
not have now I mean you can say human
beings always have at least as far as we
can think back to lived within a
technologically Rich
environment but that environment lived
as sort of an oasis in a vast Ocean or
desert however you want to put it
actually both of those are are badly put
a plethora of
nature there was a closer connection a
back and forth between the technology
the maker and the nature in which
everything else was
grounded that's different for modern man
isn't it for modern
Humanity it's very different it's even
more different for our own time than it
was in haider's time where you couldn't
cut yourself off as easily from the
outside world and the environment as you
can now think about the ubiquity of air
conditioning and the effects that that
has or the fact that with a a smartphone
you can carry around this technological
device that can Shield you from actually
having to interact with almost anything
around
you think about how people can lose
themselves in Virtual Worlds not only
for hours at a time but for days at a
time maybe modern
technology really has changed the past
pattern maybe it's revealing to us
something quite different something
radically new that is where haiger is
going and I'm just going to give you a
little bit of a prevision of this in in
in this discussion and then we'll come
back to that in a a later uh lesson or
lecture or video he
says we can say that this doesn't fit
modern machine power technology and it's
precisely the latter in it alone that is
a disturbing thing that moves us to ask
the question concerning technology per
se we're only really worried about
technology per se the essence of
Technology because we're scared of what
we've engendered of the world that we
live in because of it it is said that
modern technology is something
incomparably different from all earlier
Technologies why because it's based on
Modern physics is an exact
science and in haider's time you could
think of
mechanics um now this this is even more
true although we wouldn't say
necessarily modern physics the basis for
that as heiger is going to discuss in in
other works is essentially the
manipulation of formal systems
mathematics and the application to real
systems in which we can build these
through silicon through hardwired
circuits through the capacity of those
CC circuits to receive what we call
software um we could think of our ways
in which we've altered the environment
not only through you know Wi-Fi and
computer networks but even through our
Logistics networks which are largely uh
ways in which human beings make things
move from point A to point B so he
says the reverse holds true as well
modern physics is actually dependent on
technical apparatus and on progress in
the building of apparatus so modern
physics cannot be the answer to the
question what's different about modern
technology because modern physics not
only contributes to modern technology
and to the environment of modern
technology it also to a certain degree
requires
it presupposes it incorporates it in its
very
activity think about the advances in
physics that have been
possible just given computer modeling
which Hyer could think about at his time
but wasn't wasn't readily
available that's not a question of
physics driving technology that's a
question of Technology making something
possible for physics which then can feed
back in and you know give us models that
we can use to make the technology yet
more sophisticated there is a reciprocal
relationship there that's where we're
going to close for the time being we're
going to leave this question of well
just how is modern technology actually
different in what it's revealing to
us from previous technology we're going
to leave that question open I will throw
one word out there actually two words
one word in German two words in English
standing Reserve or band that's going to
be hager's answer to that but there's
still a lot more to cover in this and
and what we want to do at this point is
sort of take stock of how far we've come
we began with thinking about technology
in general realizing that it had to do
with instrumentality that led us through
some metaphysical examination of the
four causes which led us to examination
of responsibility of occasioning of
bringing into being of unconcealment of
Truth and now we've realized that
technology is Not Mere instrumentality
but a way of revealing to
us the very
things not only that do exist but could
exist and how it is that us human
beings can exert our responsibility in
making them happen